as he stepped out onto the taekwondo
mats bradley cinder knew he had a medal
but he'd have to kick hard to make it
gold
he pushed his opponent from uzbekistan
so close and was disappointed with silva
gotta take the swings around roundabouts
wins and losses and
each every time you perform put that
into the next time to when
to improve so on and take that into this
next cycle there's three years until
paris and i'm
hoping to do one better and bring that
gold home but age
22 in his first games it was more than
enough for his family
back in stainforth south yorkshire we
were all shouting
you know come on brad stay away stay
away
just you know keep him at bay i want
what brad wants and
he wanted he wanted gold but silva is
absolutely fantastic
the contrast with defending champion jay
jones was stark
she was expecting a third successive
gold medal but
lost in her first round against an
iranian on the refugee team
there were tears and jade jones goes
back to north wales
empty-handed she said not having my
family there to push me out of that fear
zone really did affect me
and i'm just gutted i couldn't have done
more on the day
the very first team gb medal came in
judo
chelsea giles from coventry taking
bronze
in a tough competition so finally team
gb
are up and running in tokyo after all
the success back at london 2012 and in
rio 5 years ago
expectations are now always high not
least
amongst the athletes themselves that's
why 11th in the road race was
disappointing for lizzie diegnon
andy murray has pulled out of the men's
singles due to injury but will carry on
in the doubles
but it was an 18 year old ahmed hafner
weave from tunisia who surprised
everyone in the 400 meter freestyle
landing gold from the outside lane japan
took the first ever gold medal in street
skateboarding
and out at the surfing beach with a
tropical storm approaching
the waves should get bigger the locals
would have loved to have watched the
action close up
initially we were told that local kids
would be given the opportunity to watch
it live
that's probably the saddest part to me
that they cannot anymore
i think it would have been an invaluable
experience to get to see top surface in
the world competing live
next up johnny brownlee and alex yee go
in the men's triathlon
and adam peaty might just break his own
world record
in the breaststroke final after all the
challenges the sport
is now starting to deliver tom parmenter
sky news tokyo